so democrats have been telling you we
need to lock down everybody wear a mask
do what they say
at every turn and if you don't do what
they say you're definitely going to get
covered and then
probably you're going to die there's
only one problem democrats
have been the most hypocritical actors
throughout all of this we're talking
about the most prominent democrats in
the country
routinely violating the rules they set
for everybody else regardless of whether
you think their standards are good or
whether their standards are nonsense
they're not even holding by their own
standards so they just don't have the
credibility
to even be reasonable on these subjects
we're going to go through all of it in
just one second first
this video is sponsored by mybookie okay
let's jump right in so let's start
with my former governor gavin newsom
thank god i no longer live in the state
of california
kendall gavin newsom who is just a
terrible terrible politician
and he has been constantly touting the
idea that we need shutdowns we need to
lock down
every restaurant everybody needs to wear
a mask now listen here's my personal
feeling when it comes to mask scoring
you wear a mask when you are in close
contact with other people in order to
protect them
i'm not anti-mask wearing but the sort
of virtue signaling that gavin newsom
engages in when it comes to mask wearing
is pretty ridiculous because he doesn't
give you a reasonable perspective on
where
or when to wear a mask instead it's just
wear a mask all the time
blanket rule and he's been locking down
now
outdoor restaurants in places like
california he's locking down
he's curfewing 95 of california's
population between the hours
of 10 p.m and 5 a.m so covet apparently
doesn't pass the rest of the day but
just during those hours there's only one
problem with all of this
gavin newsom doesn't pay attention to
his own rules in fact
recently he was forced to apologize
because gavin newsom decided that it was
well worthwhile to hang out at a french
restaurant a fancy french restaurant
no less with members of the california
medical association
this was not socially distanced he was
not wearing a mask
he was just enjoying himself at like 400
a plate and the pictures
are absolutely stunning he had to
apologize after doing a birthday dinner
for a well-known
lobbyist named jason kinney it's been
picked up all over the place they were
close together
right next to each other the people
sitting next to him included
janice norman a top lobbyist for the
california medical association
as well as the ceo of the california
medical association dustin corcoran
no one at the table is wearing a mask or
socially distancing
even though there's been a huge ad
campaign and a huge push
from the state government and this
forced gavin newsom to actually
apologize for a quote unquote bad
mistake meanwhile
you have chris cuomo right in the media
no one
has been more self-righteous about
masking up than chris cuomo
in the media during the spring he
suggested that he wanted everybody
to mask up any and there were people who
were out there protesting against the
lockdowns and he said you guys are
idiots
this is about other people how could you
violate the rules here's chris cuomo
then
those are the facts but there's also
feel fatigue
i've had it season's changing it's
getting warm
want to get back to it look at these
fools fools
i know they want to be out there fools
it's not about you
what about the other people and look i'm
not going to castigate you that's not my
job
i'm not your daddy but we have to think
about this
okay well then in april 2020 um he
actually got coveted 19.
and he proceeded to go ballistic on a
biker who called him out after he
engaged not necessary travel while he
had coveted because you're supposed to
isolate in place it was called a shelter
in place order not a shelter at your
second house
order i don't want some jackass loser
fat tire biker um to be able to pull
over
uh and get in my face and in my space
and talk to me i don't want to
hear it
ah the hypocrisy runs deep but you know
chris cuomo had other things to worry
about like doing
groundbreaking interviews with his
brother about how wonderful his brother
was
while not asking him a single difficult
question about his nursing home policy
in new york okay meanwhile back in
california
eric garcetti so eric garcetti actually
suggested and put in place a policy
whereby if non-essential businesses were
open during the pandemics in the early
months
he would shut off water and power we're
still getting reports
each day of non-essential businesses
that continue to operate as normal
this behavior is irresponsible and
selfish
so if you know of a shop that's failing
to do is ask give them a call
and ask them to do what's required
remind them
and if they won't refer them because if
we see
continued non-compliance they'll wind up
facing misdemeanor charge
and dwp will step in and shut off their
water and power
that did not stop eric garcetti from
showing up maskless to a black lives
matter protest because as we know
this is the most woke virus in the
history of the world it is so woke
i mean if you were protesting for social
justice you were fine in fact it was
very important
we were told by public health officials
racism was a public health problem that
was
more of a public health problem in fact
than covet itself if however you were
going to church that was a whole
different story
then there was senator dianne feinstein
also from california
so in july dianne feinstein tried to
block relief aid to states that did not
have mass mandates it was an attempt
to force all of these states into mass
mandates
then it turns out that um she went to
the airport without
a mask so that was awkward she was
reported on
carlson's show walking through the
airport with no masks that was exciting
stuff
also she walked the halls of congress
without a mask before tech hearings
so that was good stuff as well perhaps
the greatest hypocrite throughout all of
this is lori lightfoot so lori lightfoot
has been calling out people for not
wearing masks
and uh she's she's called out people who
have not engaged in the lockdowns but
she went over to the hairstylist and um
she then defended it
she said it was an essential service she
said it was very important
i'm the public face of the city i'm on
national media and i'm out in the public
eye
and you know i'm i'm i'm a person who
i take my personal hygiene very
seriously as i said i
felt like i needed to have a haircut i'm
not
able to do that myself and so i got a
haircut she said i think what people
really want to talk about we're talking
about people dying here we're talking
about
significant health disparities that's
what people care about that actually
caused
a democratic socialist named alderman
carlos ramirez rosa to go after
lightfoot ramirez rosa said she's under
no obligation to look good on national
tv
she's under no obligation to book
national interviews she is under an
obligation to follow and promote social
distancing in order to save lives
this is a bad example for our city but
no matter also lori lightfoot
fully on board with going out in the
middle of the pandemic
and after believing that joe biden won
the election shouting through a
loudspeaker of people two feet away
this is a great day for our country we
get to take our democracy back
so again what's good for you is not good
for lori lightfoot we'll get to more of
this in
just one second first
thanksgiving is about traditions like
turducken with mashed potatoes and
betting on football with my bookies
turkey day free play
my bookies third annual turkey day free
play returns thanksgiving thursday
it is your chance to bet up to 250 bucks
risk-free on the early thanksgiving game
the turkey day free play it's a no risk
all gravy wager on the full game spread
pick the right team and you win if your
team is upset your bet up to 250 bucks
is refunded before the next afternoon
game
new players get their first deposit
matched halfway up to a thousand bucks
to help add even more excitement
to the greatest football weekend of the
year that's right make your first
deposit and get extra cash you can use
on parlays teasers and props all weekend
long
use promo code shapiro in order to claim
your bonus and your free bet the best
part that's only the beginning my book
has promotions all holiday weekend long
that's why in my bookie they call
football season winning season check it
out now no risk i'll gravy baby don't
forget to use the promo code
shapiro to claim your freebies then
there's nancy pelosi so nancy pelosi has
had herself quite a pandemic
so she has suggested lockdown policies
she's done a lot of the mask
shaming but of course she lives a high
life i mean she's lived high on the hog
here
she's stood in front of a refrigerator
eating ice cream
while telling people that covet relief
you know if it got held up a little bit
was that really that big a deal here she
was
eating her 20 gelato in front of her 20
000 refrigerator talking about how
people don't really need covert relief
chocolate candy oh wow
and this is
this is something you can get through
the mail
oh my wow other people in our family
look for some other flavors but
chocolate and then we have some other
chocolate here okay but that wasn't the
extent of nancy pelosi's ridiculousness
then she was caught on tape
maskless at the hair salon so like lori
lightfoot she needed that haircut and
she needed that haircut right now
right now of course this was after she
had suggested that the president and vp
needed to wear masks in order to set an
example and
after she suggested in june that if
you're going to wear a mask it's about
protecting
other people unless you're going to the
hair salon in which case you know you're
you're basically good
is it time to mandate the wearing of
masks across the country
oh i definitely long overdue for that
and my understanding that the
centers for disease control has
recommended the use of mass but
not demand uh required it because they
don't want to offend the president
and their president should be example
you know
real men wear masks be an example to the
country
and wear the mask not only
it's not about protecting yourself it's
about protecting others
in fact in july nancy pelosi declared
that there would be a mass mandate in
the house
members and staff will be required to
wear masks
at all times in the hall of the house
except that members may remove their
masks
temporarily when recognized
the chair expects all members and staff
to adhere to this requirement
as a sign of respect for the health
safety and well-being of others
present in the chamber and surrounding
areas
okay now we move to bill de blasio back
to new york so bill de blasio has
presided over a disaster area
in new york and repeatedly violated his
own rules so
in the middle of march right as the
shutdowns were first hitting de blasio
violated
his own government recommendations and
went to the gym in brooklyn
i did not for a moment think there was
anything problematic
because i knew the dynamics and again
i have to stay healthy so i can make the
decisions for the people of the city
in november in the middle of the
pandemic he then went out in the streets
and was celebrating
joe biden's apparent victory it's
liberation it's just
joyous people have felt this weight and
a sense of we're divided
and we we shouldn't be that way and now
there's a feeling that anything's
possible that we can heal again that we
can move forward
and look joe biden and kamala harris did
something amazing
this is turning out to be a huge victory
all over the country
but it's also the beginning of the
healing that's what we need in this
country this city everywhere
but now here's the thing de blasio wants
all the dining to close the dining has
to close up again
i'm being very straightforward to all
the folks i've heard the comments
about you know how could indoor dining
still be open in gyms and i wish they
could stay open i really do
because i feel for the business owners i
feel for the people who have put their
lives into building up a business i feel
for the people who care about those
businesses
but revenge it's not it's not if it's
when and
by any normal count just looking at the
state's own number system
uh we're talking a week or two before
we're in that orange zone status
i suspect that bill de blasio is not
paying attention to all of the rules
and why don't we head on over to
pennsylvania where dr rachel levine is
the pennsylvania health secretary
and dr levine announced a robust
universal testing strategy for residents
and staff in the state's nursing homes
suggested that everything is good this
is as of may 12th that the nursing homes
were safe
we have a robust testing regimen
everything is fine
then it turns out that dr rachel levine
had
removed dr levine's mother from personal
home care
after the coveted cases were reported
there so it was good to be in a nursing
home if you were not
dr levine's mom if you're dr levine's
mom then you get to leave
my mother actually is is a resident of a
personal care home
uh not a nursing home and that is
regulated by the department of
human services not the department of
health my mother requested
and my sister and i as her children
comply to move her to another location
during the covid19 outbreak my mother is
95 years old she is very intelligent
and more than competent to make her own
decisions
i remain committed to protecting
residents in pennsylvania
wherever they live and wherever they go
good times good times
perhaps the most obvious example of
people not following their own rules
however
came courtesy from neil ferguson yale
ferguson is the the
pro-lockdown government scientist in
britain who predicted 2.2 million deaths
in the united states
absent lockdown which is a very very big
number but it turns out that professor
ferguson i was not really abiding by his
own lockdown strategy so during
britain's lockdown he was leaving his
home
to head on over to his married lover's
apartment for a tryst
in the middle of that dr ferguson was
then forced to step down not for being
crappy at his job which he
is his estimates were way off but also
for violating his own rules but
of course he should have felt free to
violate his own rules as we all know if
you are an elite member of the lockdown
cadre
you can do whatever you want the rules
simply don't apply to you now here's the
reason all this matters
we've been hearing that the experts are
telling you x y and z we've been telling
you that the experts know best
well if you are going to set a very
strict set of rules for people
as to what they can and cannot do you
then need to abide by those same rules
you don't get to violate those rules
willy-nilly because it is inconvenient
for you
if you act like a rational human being
and you take certain risks like visiting
your married lover because
you feel like she doesn't have covid and
probably you're not going to get covet
well that's your business but you don't
get to boss the rest of us around i'm
very much in favor of people being able
to make
rational risk assessments as i've said
before socially distance particularly
around people who are elderly
or vulnerable mask when you are close to
other people particularly if they are
elderly
or vulnerable be responsible in how you
treat covid right try to slow the spread
by doing the rational thing
and go to work and enjoy your life you
can do all of these things at once all
you have to do is have a little bit of
faith
in the public but of course there are so
many of our public officials who have no
faith in the public and they feel
that the rules ought to apply only to
those who are
below them they themselves no longer
have to abide by the rules
so there you have it the hypocrisy of
our elite class making the rules for
everybody else
some pigs are more equal than others